there hasn't been a significant wonder  woman centered crossover in 30 years so  everyone is showing up in the biggest  way that they can it is completely new  for wonder woman like there hasn't been  an event like this ever before a very  significant character is going to die  it's hard for me to even think about  you're going to be along for this  winding journey to find out who killed  this character you see factions form  where sometimes that can cause for some  friction  of course artemis she is so much fun to  write her and wonder woman have a long  history together they haven't always  been friends but they respect each other  a lot there's a really  an intense funeral scene the emotional  intensity there this is pretty powerful  stuff like if i do say so myself  you